[Music]
as we told you President Trump announced
Friday was commuting the sentence of
Roger stone just days before stone was
set to start a three plus year prison
sentence stemming from Robert Muller's
Russian witch-hunt member stone was
convicted of processed crimes relating
in 2017 and statements he made to house
lawmakers in other words lying before
Congress huh
Adam Schiff presiding the biggest liar
in Congress now neither the shift' show
nor robert muller produced one bit of
evidence that stone was working with
anybody colluding with russia and by the
way as the White House press secretary
explained quote these charges were the
product of recklessness born of
frustration and malice joining us now
Roger stone first TV interview and his
attorney David Schon
I would like to say to you Roger well
I'm glad you had your sentence commuted
and you're not headed to prison this
week there's a part of me that is also
very angry and very concerned for the
country based on the entire handling of
your matter why don't I just let you say
it in your own words what this has been
like for you well this is the most
horrible experience you can have because
I see immediately why 99% of the people
who choose to plead not guilty and go to
trial lose when you're up against the
horrific and deep-pocketed resources of
the of the federal government and these
really sadistic arrogant politically
motivated prosecutors it's and I had a
bias judge I had a stacked jury I had a
corrupted jury forewoman as my friend
Tucker Carlson said my trial was over
before it started and when you go
through something like this Sean you
find out who your real friends are and
who the people are who really never were
your friends you had been a tremendous
friend you have done a great job of
keeping people in form but I have to
really single out your Fox News
colleague Tucker Carlson he took up the
cudgels early he stayed on this case
with every twist and turn wasn't afraid
to take on the judge
the jury question encouraged me when I
got discouraged he's a man of incredible
loyalty and he's a he's a great friend
he made me the best friend a man can
have so my hats off to him and also
congressman Matt gates from Florida who
I hope to live long enough to see in the
White House he was a great friend who
never gave up and tried to make sure
everybody understood the injustice that
I had been through but so many others
Bernie Kerik the former New York police
commissioner and Charley Kirk Reverend
Franklin Graham pastors mark burns and
in Darrell Scott you know Randy Coggins
a dynamic young evangelist from Florida
the entire Flynn family general Mike
Flynn man who's still being persecuted
my hat's off to all of them because they
helped me and my wife and my family
through the scariest most difficult
process of you can imagine but above all
I must tell you
Sean based on advice from you and and an
Reverend Graham and and the two pastors
I mentioned I really want to thank God
because I was literally hours away from
being sent to a kovat infested prison in
violation of the current Bureau of
Prisons and DOJ policies in violation of
every precedent in the country where
people going to jail or in jail were
asking for compassionate release and in
every case it was granted I'm 67 years
old I've had a lifelong problem of
respiratory problems I was facing what I
really believed was a near death
sentence so you let me particularly
Tucker Matt Gaetz and everybody I named
my heart goes out to you I'm deeply
deeply grateful but more than anything
else I'm grateful for God because as you
told me if I would if I would read a
material I remember he born he I could
remember it like it was yesterday and
your advice was as solid as can be
you said God will never desert you he
will never abandon you he will protect
you if you if you confess your sins and
you walk in his way and I have done my
very
to do that let me go through and I want
you to tell people because this there's
this whole system of justice where you
can use Sammy the bull Gravano as the
biggest case in point he commits 19
murders and he's given a
get-out-of-jail-free card and a witness
protection program because he flipped on
on John Gotti all right put that aside
for a second in your case did Muller and
his team offer anything of value your
freedom for example I would argue is of
great value if you would say certain
things they wanted you to say whether
they were true or not well in the
beginning of the case Shawn I don't
think that was their intention but as
they got closer and closer to having to
issue the Mulder report and they
realized that they had no rush in
collusion because there was no rush
inclusion it was a hoax on July 24th
Gene Erie who was heading my prosecution
within of the Muller team that's
extraordinary in itself because she
previously represented Hillary Clinton
and the Clinton Foundation in the
illegal email server case in the missing
email case so she had a clear bias she
was a maximum donor to both of Hillary's
presidential campaigns by the way she
has all the charm of a North Korean
prison guard she made it very clear to
one of my lawyers after hearing she
asked to see him privately that if I
would remember certain phone
conversations I have with candidate
Trump if I would come clean if I would
confess that they that they might be
willing to you know recommend leniency
to the judge perhaps I wouldn't even
serve any jail time and I didn't have to
think about it very long I said
absolutely not there was no circumstance
under which I would bear false witness
against the president I was I was just
not willing to lie now in the last two
days when I said that people said ah you
see stone had the goods on Trump and he
traded his silence for for commutation
that is patently false I never said that
I never implied that what I said has
been consistent that I would not lie
against my
friend of 40 years so they could use it
for impeachment they wanted me to be the
ham in their ham sandwich because they
knew the Muller report particularly on
Russia was a dud
it was a goose egg they had nothing and
they were hoping that I would
recharacterize my phone calls
I think these phone calls that were plea
bargain induced claims by Michael Cohen
and Ric Gates for which they could never
find any corroboration and I simply
refused to do it
let me go to you David shown and I'll
ask you both the same question
simultaneously Roger I think I've known
you well enough over the years you're a
fighter your instincts are going to be
okay now I'm going to go back and I'm
maybe if you go back and you appeal this
and you open up this case again I would
I would argue right now you're home free
and I think that I saw nothing but
corruption in that courtroom by that
judge and that jury and not giving you
another trial David I would say that if
you go forward with that you are now
putting Rogers life back in jeopardy
again and I don't know you're right I
don't have any faith in that system I
don't have any faith in that judge I
don't have any faith with that jury
nobody on this case do I believe is
honorable here I think you're right you
raise a very interesting question in a
perplexing one we have to sit down and
make a decision as to whether to go
forward with the appeal
knowing that a win in this case and
there should be a win classic Fifth and
Sixth Amendment violations would go
right back to the same judge and a
courtroom of injustice let me just say
this to you this commutation is a great
tribute to President Trump for three
reasons he sends the message that the
Muller team was rotten to the core
from its inception when mr. Muller
picked a man's right three years David
Schwimmer rang it you don't pick in the
an investigation that involves the
President of the United States requires
integrity you don't pick an Andrew
Weissman who is the most ethically
bankrupt prosecutor I've ever come
across I represent two men right now
mr. Arena mr. Sesa who were wrongfully
convicted with him you talked about
making deals with witnesses he lied
about those deals he was mentioned
specifically by a judge for his
misconduct so that's one thing the
Muller team was rotten to the core
or filled with partisans number two an
unfair trial the president recognized
that they didn't the judge denied the
entire defense theory mr. stone wasn't
allowed to mention on social media or
make a defense theory that in any way
challenged the integrity of the Muller
team unprecedented and thirdly the
president saved a life here because the
judge's decision on denying a surrender
extension when kovat was in the prison
and with these health conditions goes
against all authority in the country on
this issue as did the court of appeals
you know
I'm listening to your attorney and I
don't date about a long time Roger I've
known you a long time and you're a
character everybody knows you're a
character but that's not about you as
the character I would want a fair and
impartial jury for everybody I wouldn't
want any Democrat or liberal to have 29
guys in tactical gear over-processed
crime I wouldn't want a gag order on any
American they should have a right to
speak out in their own defense I
wouldn't want a jury foreperson as
prejudiced or a judge that went along
with this crap my question to you is
we've seen this now with Papadopoulos
we've now seen this with Paul Manafort
we saw it with general Flynn we've seen
it with you I'll be honest Roger I
believe in our Constitution I believe in
our rule of law I think I read a lot
about equal justice and application of
our laws I don't see any of this in any
of these cases I see a travesty of
injustice you've been a part of it I
don't know I'll be losing faith in the
system Roger well it's like you have a
good reason to if you examine the DC
Circuit Court of Appeals where I had to
file last-minute emergency appeal of
judge Jackson's rule sending me to jail
she ignored all the legal precedents in
that she ignored my health conditions
she ignored the conditions at the prison
at that time and she ignored the current
policies of DOJ and the BL P now you
would have thought that that would have
been reversed in the appeals court but
they ruled for her three to zero I'm
afraid this is a fixed system above
although I guess I'd have to say the
most important thing here is the
courageousness of the president's act I
know there were many many many people
who told him intellect
year don't do this let Roger stone wait
maybe for a pardon after the election
Shawn I don't think I would have lived
that long
not with my asthmatic condition not with
now 60 Cove in nineteen cases in that
prison so I have deep deep affection for
Donald Trump because I've known him 40
years he's a man of great justice and
fairness he's a man of enormous courage
I knew he took would take some shots for
this but I think most people most
fair-minded people understand he saved
my life and at least on paper he gave me
a chance to fight for vindication now
I'm not a fool I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
guided by the advice of my lawyers as I
understand it if I my conviction is
overturned by the appeals court I'd be
back in front of Judge Jackson judge
Jackson issued incredible ruling it said
that I could not raise misconduct by the
Special Counsel the FBI the DOJ or any
member of Congress Adam Schiff so I mean
if that were in place in general Flynn's
case we still wouldn't know how he was
railroaded we still wouldn't know about
the political motivations behind taking
him down so I've got to become convinced
I can get a fair second trial because I
certainly didn't get a fair first trial
you had a gag order and you weren't
allowed to even put on your defense you
wanted to put on a defense they denied
you that right then of course we have
the whole jury foreperson this is on top
of the raid pre-dawn raid by the way I'm
sure you probably call CNN Roger and
said that here is I do not believe you
can get any fair trial
in that courtroom or that system I don't
know I think that probably every fiber
of your being would want to be to fight
to get the acquittal you believe you
should get but I don't know if I'd give
you that advice because I don't think
there's anybody in that courtroom that
is fair Roger well and as you point out
Comey clapper Brennan mccabe struck page
Rosenstein muller himself Hillary they
all lied
under oath but they lied about material
things consequential things therefore
they had an intent and a motive to lie I
I was charged with making mistakes that
were innocuous and if you look at it
very carefully it's very clear what
happened here and that is that Aaron
szalinski the corrupt prosecutor the
dirtiest
of Muller's dirty cops other than
Weissman shared the fruits of the
surveillance into me with Adam Schiff so
that he could fashion got your questions
most of them of no consequence and then
after the setup in which I appeared
voluntarily before the House
Intelligence Committee chef in violation
of house rules shared the the classified
testimony with mr. szalinski so mr.
Weissman could fashion a very contorted
and contrived indictment yet today you
have Muller and Schiff and Rosenstein
back to saying stone was in cahoots with
Russian intelligence this is nonsense
they're all the way back to the Russian
of Russia whatever any evidence they
know it's there was the key was there
any evidence ever given of any contact
with any question Intel hears if there
was there there there was there was
evidence that I had a twitter direct
message exchange with gusoff 4.2 a
persona but if you look at when that
happened it happened long after
WikiLeaks had published all their
material and if you look at the actual
content of the exchange it's benign
there's no pollution there's no
collaboration and thirdly we don't even
know that goofs were 2.0 is a Russian
asset just because John Brennan says
something's true he said the steel
dossier was real too so just because
they assert something doesn't mean it's
true
I could have proved at trial using
forensic evidence and expert testimony
from fellows like Bill Benny former SNA
counterintelligence expert and Ray
McGovern that no one hacked to the DNC
that there was no online hack of the DNC
that the information based on the
download times was downloaded to a
portable disk and taken out the backdoor
but I wasn't allowed to present that
defense because judge Jackson would not
allow it Roger I want to believe in our
system adjusted
in a way worked I guess in the end with
the president's commutation but what
happened to you what happened to
Papadopoulos what happened to General
Flynn what happened to mana fort what
happened to the President of the United
States what happened to Carter page
we're gonna lose this country if this
happens again
it's the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal in our history glad
you're free tonight Roger we wish you
Godspeed and David thank you for the
great work you do as his attorney